so question for the women have you ever
approached a guy
and have you ever been rejected
no yes yes yeah oh cool okay tell me
tell me about it I've approached but not
been rejected oh you've never been
rejected you have you approached yeah
have you been rejected yeah what
happened
um it's just when I open up and say what
I want from my future and what I like
for example that I want to be married
and I want to have family they tend to
be like you said that immediately yeah
have you ever cold approached uh I think
I have
at a bar at a club yeah they're always
into it yeah okay what about you have
you ever called approach no no no have
you ever called approached
I don't think so no that's interesting
right I would know I don't know I don't
think so no I have yeah
no never yeah
what about you have you ever approached
a guy yeah were you ever rejected yes
really yeah how what do you say
um I remember like once I was like in
the grocery there was this really hot
guy like it was like John like exactly
no there was like my type like this and
then I was like oh my God but I was like
you know it was like civil engineer work
in a site construction so well like
almost like the majority of my time I
wasn't like dressed up I wasn't like
cute it was like with boots like jeans
like you know
and then I kick him up to him and he
said oh I'm sorry I'm married and I said
okay
he's married that's good
and I think like when I was younger too
like I I don't know I think getting
rejected is like part of life yeah
I'm curious from the guys is there a
rejection that was like your worst
rejection that you can think of well
I've called the push like probably tens
of thousands of times but you know every
now and then there'll be a girl who just
tells you to [__] off or like tries to
insult you personally or something like
that and that that can hurt sometimes
right you get over that like you just
you just learn that's gonna happen
sometimes but especially for like
clients that aren't used to approaching
if they hear something that early on
where the person says like oh no I don't
like you because of this and this that
sticks in their head and they think
every girl thinks that and it can be
like debilitating and I can take them
out of the game I think for me the the
worst approach
um rejections I can remember is when
they don't say anything they pretend
they don't hear you no they look at you
like how dare you even think you have
what it takes to come up to me and I
don't say it's just everything in the
eyes it's saying that and you feel like
some girls friend they don't hear you
too like they just stand there but it'd
be nice if they're pretending they don't
think about the ones that hurt you
you're like
almost insulted that you come up to them
that happened to me like two days ago
with the girl okay I I just was
complimenting her outfit I was like oh
my gosh that's so cute she just looked
at me no and I know she's I know she
heard me and then she just like kept
like because I was sitting at like a
table bar you know what I mean and she
just kept she just like looked the other
way okay then then I go to this other
place right and she's there and then she
she starts talking to me and she's like
can you take my Instagram picture I'm
like [__]
I'm like [__] I just said hello
again
so I feel you that that was that was my
but that was when I was young now I'm
like I'm so it's it becomes almost like
funny though like in the beginning like
if a girl would ignore I'd be like oh my
God like I'm horrible yeah but now like
if I got to a bar and I'm like okay I
want to meet you real quick and the
girl's like pretend she doesn't hear
I'll be like I know you hear me can I
just talk to her a sec if they're still
not responsive then I'll just walk away
you know I just walk away right away but
it doesn't even register you get to the
point I mean if I was single as well I
was like you just don't care yeah but
it's almost like it's almost like funny
too you're like look at this okay the
chat is saying tell me you didn't take
her picture I did I'm not even going
[Music]
back
but they're good food yeah I was like
that's what I'm good for I feel like I'm
a part he had one minute of a lifetime
for so many years yeah yeah I was like I
don't like this look at that woman that
became a man for a bit wasn't it the
story where she became a masturbate she
committed suicide on the life the
surface they say yeah which was only a
man for a short time well I don't think
most women aren't like I don't think we
really noticed the privilege we're given
in society just from being young women
where we're like treated better by
people and the first time this happened
to me I am I worked in a sales job and I
was the only girl in the office and
people would always help me with
whatever I wanted you know what I mean
yeah and all the guys around me would be
like oh it's because you're a girl it's
because you're a girl and I was like no
it's because I'm so bubbly and I work
hard
yeah okay yeah and then I found out it
was in fact because I was a girl because
I feel like you're not even in like a
romantic way but I think that men just
have more of an inclination to like help
yeah they were fun than helping a guy
what it's more fun than helping a guy
yeah even if it's not like it also goes
the other way though because then
there's also a sense of not taking women
as seriously as well so it flips doesn't
it I've never had like I've never felt
that was an issue to be honest and I've
worked in like predominantly male
dominated Fields I think it's an
advantage not a disadvantage yeah but I
think you've probably learned how to you
know you're a powerful woman so you've
learned how to I'm the same I will
always navigate whatever
you know limitations to say based on Me
based as a black man for instance I
don't care yeah some people don't learn
that skill so they actually internalize
no I'm not enough excuse I think there's
zero limitations as a woman like zero
none unless it's like a string I agree
I'm not gonna lie yeah I feel like the
girls that whine about going to
corporate and having a hard time like I
just think it's an excuse they're just
big whiners I don't think so Pearl I
have to say there is there is a listen
there's women do get treated by
compassion people help them out but
there's also the view of like oh women
is it weaker than a man and there's
nothing wrong with that logic like
physically woman is weaker than a man
but if a woman's trying to get some
level of finances or authority she will
definitely get a backlash of like you're
a woman I disagree I think there's quote
there's quotas for women I think women
get put in positions they shouldn't be
in all the time what do you mean like I
feel like women get put in positions
they're actually not qualified for and
they're not the best person for the job
because of quotas and diversity Hunters
yeah some some um
where women or people of color do have
to prove themselves more in order to be
getting taken seriously no so I just
think as for women in my experience I I
don't think there's any disadvantage and
most of the girls I know that complain
about it are just kind of lazy to be
honest I don't agree with you perro I
get you but I don't agree with you given
that I'm with my partner and sometimes I
go for what he's going for I put my
hands up I don't speak as perfect
English and I'm not intelligent as much
as he is but there's a lot of positions
that he gets picked when I don't you
know maybe he's just better he is
unfortunately yes that's right but
there's sometimes when they give him
chances but give me a chance to just
prove that I'm better or maybe I'm equal
in some there is a lot of places that
I'm quite equal but I feel like it's
like a mindset thing like if I if I get
passed up for a job with a dude like I'm
not gonna think it's because of my
gender I'm thinking I'm gonna think it's
because I'm not good enough yeah but
that's what I mean there's two different
things at play one there is and a
disadvantage for some people in society
whether it's based on your race whatever
it might be even height they've showed
studies about that but I think the
second thing is who are you in the face
of that and that's what you're alluding
to yeah so I don't care there are times
of course I mean I've grown up as a
young black boy how many times I've got
stopped by police of course
statistically I knew there was more I
have friends that would walk around with
whatever in their pockets they never get
stopped because I do I get it it's a
reality but my thing is who are you
going to be in the face of it that's the
difference so I recognize that Society
does treat different people differently
that's that's just true but my thing is
I don't do the victim thing because of
it I think that's what you're talking
about you're not a victim in fact I
actually turn it on his head because it
happened I'm gonna go even harder that's
it you know I was brought up told you
you're black you're gonna have to work
three times
yeah I'm not going to complain no why is
it three times
and it's given me an advantage
disadvantage gives you an advantage you
see it with like rappers in that they're
hungry get the way they come from they
mean it when they say get rich or die
trying there are discrimination against
them but it makes them what I don't like
is victim culture but I just I think
that Society openly discriminates
against men way more than women and that
like and I
a case like there wouldn't be voters in
these jobs yeah like I think people want
women in leadership positions because in
a lot of companies they have diversity
hires true but that's quite a recent
thing I would say probably isn't in the
last generation I mean it's been
implemented since like the 60s at least
in the US since the 60s yeah last
animation or two yeah but that's I mean
I'm 26 so that's two of two of my
lifetimes that's quite a long time to me
it's the pendulum thing isn't it I think
it's sung too far now it still sounds
like let's get someone diverse in there
even though they're not I mean I think
about I'm bad that I say but our
Chancellor of course an absolute
nightmare I wonder if he was thrust in
that position the next thing you know he
had the most terrible him in the prime
minister is trust you know that's an
example I think where people just put
into position because they can agreement
swinging I actually don't really see it
like women were discriminated against
like ever because I just think that we
had different roles like we could say
that men were discriminated against
because they had to go to war we didn't
have to go I don't think I just think
Society was set up differently I don't
think it's discrimination in that I mean
give an example for instance right if it
wasn't for the fact that men went to war
women would never been allowed in these
industrial jobs it's not discrimination
it's just a limitation based on an
assumption of your woman you can't do it
strength you know or you're black you
can't do it well I mean I think when it
comes to war like we can't
now but women did women did fill the
positions that men left behind I was
talking about war oh actually going yeah
I mean me and you could fight your even
if I'm the strongest woman you're gonna
win
physically yeah I mean there are some
female climbers out there that run rings
around something if women were doing so
well in the military they wouldn't
continually lower the requirements for
them
it's true like they literally had to
lower the requirement for us to become a
seal I think when it's physically like
that but definitely in society there
have been instances where people have
not been given a chance because of an
assumption about what they were capable
of and when they were given that chance
you could see that they excelled I mean
as a time the NBA wasn't full of black
players you know there were times to
answer we've got a friend who's um a
black um football agent there was a time
that was unheard of the other time when
women weren't seen able to run a
football club and yeah I'm just talking
about gender yeah so when my what I was
talking about was when I just don't
think women were ever really
discriminated against I think Society
was different
okay
I don't know I I think do you find
discrimination what's the definition of
discrimination about like earning
differentials right even the modern days
because of their gender isn't it really
is well I come from a culture when it's
the opposite to the West right now women
do get abused I was about to say these
are the people that I know personally
the man will cheat she can't say any
word and she will get hit and there's no
one's gonna stand for her she goes to
play her parents stay in that marriage
you've got kids and you're not coming
back to us
I'm talking about in the west I don't
know what but that's what I'm saying we
could do different things right but
that's one he says it's been shifted
right so there's a lot of women right
happen because of that because it that
was like 100 years ago here so the woman
stood and raised their voice but it
became quite toxic right now and I think
what's really missing is balance as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible